depuis près de 15 ans la talon Academy
propose des ateliers pour apprendre à
marcher avec des chaussures à talons
vous ne rêvez pas si le concept peut
prêter à sourire c'est du sérieux marché
en talon ça s'apprend et donc vous êtes
à l'origine de la création de cette
école et alors avant de commencer à
parler de des cours des ateliers que
vous mettez en place pour apprendre à
marcher avec des talons je voulais vous
poser la question c'est ninja est-ce que
vous êtes plutôt team talon ou team
basket je dirais team basket parce que
je suis un peu grande et j'avoue j'ai
jamais vraiment osé porter des talons
qui me rendent encore plus grande je
fais facilement en 1m85 avec des talons
donc team basket et justement c'est un
peu votre objectif finalement aimer de
de décomplexer ces femmes qui qui
n'osent pas marcher en talon alors c'est
tout à fait ça c'est tout à fait
l'objectif des ateliers à la à la talon
Academy j'ai principalement des des
jeunes femmes qui vont de 35 jusqu'à 65
ans elles sont encore très
et du coup elles viennent soit
réapprendre à marcher en talon parce que
malheureusement le covid est passé par
là et ça a permis de renfiler ses
baskets et surtout j'ai aussi de très
jeunes filles qui viennent vraiment se
lancer et apprendre à marcher
effectivement elle passe du 4 au 7
parfois certaines mamelles jusqu'à du 11
cm mais je sais calmer les ardeurs de
chacune et alors dans le cas de Céline
charme on peut quand même porter des
talons quand on est grande bien sûr bien
sûr j'encourage bon courage et on trouve
toujours chaussures à son pied en plus
c'est très joli il y en a il y en a
vraiment qui me font de l'oeil mais
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt un complexe
effectivement de et ben il ne faut pas
parce que moi j'accueille les femmes
justement pour les décomplexer et je
vous invite si vous voulez à nous
rejoindre
mais alors quand même les baskets c'est
un peu plus confortable que les talons
pour marcher avec toute la journée
est-ce que vous avez des conseils pour
nous pour éviter d'avoir mal aux pieds
ou pour éviter de tomber avec des talons
alors les talons il faut déjà commencer
par apprendre avec du 4 cm c'est pas la
peine de se percher tout de suite et
c'est une question d'entraînement c'est
c'est un sport donc en montant sur du 4
cm vous allez progresser au fur et à
mesure moi mes apprentis ce que je leur
dis une fois qu'elle sorte de l'atelier
c'est simplement de s'entraîner un
maximum un maximum de temps qu'elle
fasse la vaisselle avec leurs talons
qu'elles veillent chercher le pain puis
après elle s'aventure dans la ville de
plus en plus loin par contre
effectivement pour ne pas souffrir en
talon moi j'encourage vraiment à
progresser en hauteur et surtout à ne
pas hésiter à équiper l'intérieur de ces
souliers avec divers accessoires
d'accessoires alors il existe maintenant
beaucoup d'accessoires en silicone
totalement transparent et qui permettent
vraiment d'éviter toute souffrance et de
rester très longtemps parce que les
talons c'est très chic quand on va un
cocktail et c'est très important de ne
pas avoir cette brûlure sous le
coussinet il existe maintenant
effectivement des petits accessoires en
silicone voir en tissu voire même en
mousse qui vous permet d'assouplir cette
cet échauffement voilà et puis pareil
derrière les talon voilà derrière les
talons c'est toujours ça le principal
problème
l'ampoule voilà donc il faut pas hésiter
il faut coller tout de suite à
l'intérieur de la chaussure un petit
accessoire souvent en mousse qui permet
d'éviter voilà les ampoules et si vous
voulez une très bonne recette le mieux
c'est d'hydrater ses pieds chaque matin
le conseil est brisé
vous l'avez du coup amené plusieurs
paires de chaussures devant vous elles
sont toutes un peu différentes je vois
il y a des talons un peu plus fin que
d'autres tout à fait moi j'ai une grande
passion pour les talons originaux donc
vous voyez celle-ci mon mari me les a
offerts pour la Saint-Valentin et on
voit bien le cœur et la flèche qui tire
à l'intérieur donc celle-ci elles ont
l'air un peu compliquées quand même pour
marcher avec ça alors le talon est en
triangle effectivement c'est un tri
c'est un talon aiguille avec un petit
triangle donc il faut quand même une
bonne maîtrise là après vous avez ce
type de chaussures avec des talons
virgule elles sont absolument
magnifiques moi ça c'était vraiment un
rêve d'achat et j'en ai profité pour
économiser pendant plusieurs mois pour
me les acheter il faut savoir et j'ai
pas honte de le dire que j'ai entre 300
et 400 paires de chaussures vous arrivez
à toutes les porter bah écoutez je peux
emporter une paire par jour et ça c'est
formidable je vous tiens un peu plus
d'un an quoi
non je les porte pas tous J'ai des
pièces très rares que je ne porte pas du
tout par peur de les abîmer et puis il y
a les talons que je porte couramment
sans aucun problème donc il y a aussi
une paire de talons avec des talons rose
flash alors les talons sont roses flash
mais c'est pas ça l'argument de base
c'est vraiment c'est un ce qu'on appelle
un talon amovible et ça c'est vraiment
génial puisqu'on peut progresser sur on
va dire du 2 3 cm et au cours de la
journée on peut monter et descendre
comme on le souhaite on peut changer les
couleurs de talon changer les formes de
chaussures et ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose que je recommande quand on part au
bureau le matin on est sur des
ballerines on peut remonter dans la
journée et on n'a pas besoin de changer
de chaussures pour partir en soirée
directement il suffit de monter un peu
plus en talon et un peu plus en forme
puisqu'elles existent en forme talon
aiguille d'accord je connaissais pas du
tout
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire
une petite démonstration peut-être de ce
qu'il faut faire et ce qui ne faudrait
pas faire justement il y a peut-être des
démarches à éviter je vous laisse avec
grand elle est tranquillement sur sur le
plateau qu'on a préparé pour vous
voilà alors vous pouvez nous montrer des
rouler du pied alors le déroulé du pied
je vais me permettre d'enlever donc mes
souliers parce que c'est important
beaucoup de femmes ne connaissent pas le
dessous de leurs pieds et le pied c'est
vraiment c'est un accessoire du corps
qui est là mais auquel on se préoccupe
pas alors que c'est quand même un
élément très important dans la vie ils
vont nous porter jusqu'à la fin de nos
jours donc le déroulé du pied c'est ce
principe là c'est à dire qu'on va poser
le talon puis on va dérouler son pied
alors évidemment on va pas non plus
poser le talon comme un comme un sauvage
on va le poser simplement et on va
dérouler dans la chaussure voilà et
surtout la chose la plus importante
c'est de ne jamais faire de pas
gigantissime comme ça parce que quand on
porte des talons on est une princesse et
on doit être remarqué il y a beaucoup de
maris qui qui m'écoutent là et qui vont
crier en disant ouais mais il faut que
j'attende ma femme derrière mais
justement le principe le principe c'est
de marcher doucement voilà parce qu'on
est une princesse et qu'on doit marcher
doucement et on doit se faire remarquer
quand on est en quand on porte des
talons c'est très très important et
alors qu'est-ce qui ne faut pas faire et
met un verre alors ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire et ce que je vois malheureusement
souvent bah c'est des démarches qui ne
sont pas travaillées alors vous avez la
principale chose c'est qu'il faut pas
faire des grands pas comme ça bien sûr
et d'autres lignées comme ça c'est pas
la peine
et je vois beaucoup de femmes beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes qui croisent les
jambes parce qu'elles voudraient toutes
les femmes au monde voudrait des
mannequins et du coup on a tendance à
croiser façon mannequin mais là je vous
dis pas pour la posture du dos le bas
des vertèbres c'est la chose qui n'est
pas absolument pas faire et que je le
recommande pas du tout c'est pauvre
mannequin qui défilent pour la haute
couture croyez moi que c'est pas évident
de marcher comme ça tout le temps vous
avez
peut-être un peu les fesses mais voilà
vous vous détruisez votre dos il faut
vraiment avoir une posture droite un
regard lointain évitez de regarder ses
pieds bien sûr même quand on est dans
une grande ville et que il y a des
obstacles on doit voir les obstacles on
doit les c'est comme en voiture on doit
aller enfin assurer voilà assurer ça
marche et puis simplement voilà dérouler
le pied correctement et il y a aucun
problème et vous pouvez marcher très
longtemps comme ça
et bien merci beaucoup et ben un beurre
pour cette démonstration on va prendre
notre Céline charme on va essayer j'ai
pris quelques notes de marché en talon
de cette façon merci beaucoup d'avoir
partagé votre passion pour les
chaussures à talons je vous laisse
revenir en plateau tranquillement alors
si vous êtes intéressé par un cours
collectif de 10 personnes c'est environ
40 euros pour les deux heures et aimer
un verre fait également des cours
particuliers de 4 heures